[Music]
when you had a baby it didn't come with
an instruction manual
nobody said here's your instruction
manual to
change the diaper or be a mom or nurse
that baby or feed the baby
there's no instruction manual to be an
entrepreneur
yes you can read a lot of books and you
can get a lot of advice but at the end
of the day
take a step forward be action oriented
gsdn right get done now less than one
percent of the ad agencies on the planet
are women out that's crazy life is too
short
and your goals are too big just start
taking steps
ladies and gentlemen believe nation
barbara jolison in the house
uh she runs ludwig plus one of
the top marketing branding agencies in
the world
spends most of her time helping giant
corporations that you know
and love build amazing like go look at
the ludwig plus portfolio you'll see
just
beautiful designs um that put everything
i do to shame so i'm super jealous
and and i thought hey let's have iran to
talk about strategies for
entrepreneurs so we can tap into that
genius brain of hers
and see what we can learn to brand
ourselves better because we may not be
able to afford a full service agency yet
barbara welcome aboard thanks it's great
to be here evan thanks
so one of the things that you had i
don't know if it's on your bio or right
somewhere
um you wrote this down what you do is
unearth a brain
soul and and i just love that concept
what's the first thing that you do so if
somebody came and said barbara
we need help with our branding help us
unearth our soul like what do you
what do you then do what's your process
oh my gosh this is so
fun okay so you know it it all
starts from the inside out right i mean
that's
to really deliver something you got to
really
immerse yourself in a business and
understand
what who makes up the company who are
the people what do they do
how do they work right and um and
deliver this authentic message about who
a company is
and i think often marketers
will make the mistake of not really
rolling their sleeves up
and uh going all in to understand what a
business is about
so the first thing we do is we'll do
what we
you know uh discovery sessions and talk
to
every level of the company to understand
who they are and what they're about
and that's that's the starting point so
so for the entrepreneurs out there who
don't have lots of people in the company
aka it's just them who's wearing every
hat
what would you go through with them in
the discovery session to help them start
to get more clarity
well it really starts with i mean what's
fun here's what's fun about being an
entrepreneur is
it's um you you get to start from zero
right you get to start from scratch and
you get
to articulate what you want to be right
and
and you got to have i say have really
really big aspirations
don't think about what you are today
think about what you're going to become
and then take a step back and say what's
it going to take for me to get there
and then make a list of all those things
that are going to take for you to get
there and it might be
i need people i need technology i need
certain products i need certain
resources right
and you make that list and then you say
okay well what can i do
today tomorrow
literally what can i literally do today
to start to take a step toward that
you know big big vision
and so you just take one step at a time
right it's
all everything every inch gets you to
that big idea
how much of your discovery sessions
are really you allowing people to dream
it's all about dreaming right because
you want to you want to do something
that is
that has a purpose right and especially
if you're going to grow a business
people want to be part of something
bigger um
they don't want to just do a job or they
don't want to just
buy a product right and think about it
and think about the things you buy every
single day
right you don't buy just a generic
bottle of water you might
right but there are people who buy into
certain brands
and it's the same thing whether it's
your people buying into
who you are and what you're going to
become or it's your customers or your
clients who
want to be a part of what you're
building
right and so i say dream big um have
really and and sometimes it's
interesting some companies and some
people that i work with are very
um heady and iq and sometimes it's hard
for them to tap into their eq
um and so we'll find exercises and ways
to tap into
that big emotional aspiration so that
you can have that
that big purposeful and intentional
business that you're creating so when
somebody comes in and they're they're
sharing their their vision and you feel
like
they're not dreaming big and there's you
know there's more inside their soul than
what they're
sharing how do you get them out of their
own way
and their story and their limiting
beliefs or mindset to actually
have permission to dream big right well
everybody's different right so we'll
start we always start off with
what do you know it's easy for somebody
to say oh i want to build my business to
be
this big this number number one top ten
whatever their business goals are
but then you you literally have to keep
asking why
and peel back that onion until you can
get to them
talking about what what's your purpose
and why would anyone
want to be part of that and what are you
delivering that's going to be different
and that's really what unearthing the
soul of a brand
is about right it's saying what is that
bigger why and you look at brands out
there who have
incredible vision statements look at
tesla
they have an amazing vision statement
accelerate
uh sustainable energy right
accelerate the development of
sustainable energy it's huge
right you look at a lot of big brands
and they have these big
big goals and so people want to be part
of something bigger
and then you map out your plan to get
there and so i think
um like i said some people have a harder
time
articulating that and if they do we'll
take them through exercises and you know
we do a lot of work
in a variety of categories whether it's
healthcare or housing
and take housing for example we might do
an exercise around
the word home and what does home mean
to you and that allows them to start to
unearth
everything that word means and then what
we'll say is okay well
what does that look like in your
business to help them start to see
the potential of that vision and that
idea
i know a big part of what you are proud
of is that you're a woman-owned agency
and it's on the website and it's on the
you know instagram and it's rare
in in your industry maybe a lot of
marketing
folks a lot of marketing agencies and i
have a you know woman at the top is
amazing she's like we gotta have her on
uh
is that i mean making that front and
center is that
to try to be an inspiration to others or
like what's
what's the story of making that front
center for you less than one percent of
the ad agencies on the planet
are women owned that's crazy why
is that insane i mean i don't get it
so what what do you think like why is it
less than one percent that's a crazy
number why is it so low
you know i think it's just you know the
culturally
i think you know women did not get into
obviously women weren't as
active in the workforce for so many
years and i think you know the trends of
um being a professional and being a mom
all of those have challenged women to be
um
you know able to you know pursue their
professional
careers um and by the way i just
for the record i'm the mom of four of my
own and four step sons so eight boys
eight boys that's amazing
out there you know just do it all um
but i think it's important i think that
um setting
um you know it's in a way it's you
talked about aspirations and
big big aspirations as a company i want
people to be able to go for it right
and for young women entering their
career realizing that they can do this
too
um and um you know pursue whatever it is
you want to pursue
and personally and professionally
but be focused on both be great at both
and you can
there's room to do it all i mean you
know i i might do a call
at the lacrosse field i did one last
night
but that's okay because i'm i'm able to
you know go off at halftime do a call
get back and i'm on the field rooting my
boys on so
um but i think women known as important
um
there it's a big focus for um equality
in the workplace
i think that um women should be
able to pursue whatever they want to
pursue or anybody for that matter i
don't think
you know we we have all walks of life
here at ludwig plus and
and we're a great place to allow people
to realize their full potential
i've been doing youtube videos since
2009
at the time when it kind of wasn't cool
to make business entrepreneur
you know youtube videos but i've seen a
big shift since
then to now of the the amount of
women in my audience in the demographics
is
it's still not equal i'd say it's like
60 40 men to women but that's way
more than what it used to be back in
2009
and it's just amazing to see how many
women are wanting to start their own
business and
it's never been more possible to to be
an entrepreneur i mean you kind of had
to be crazy
30 years ago to do it but it's never
been more possible
to do it now so that's why it's so
shocking it's like why especially in
what you do
with with the with eq being so
prized it's just feels so shocking it's
less than one percent
isn't that incredible it's true though
and there's a lot of women in the
advertising industry um
a lot of you know not a lot of women
leading advertising
agencies and not a lot of women leading
big corporations right
and so i think you know showing showing
young women
and other women or women who may be left
to have
their kids and they want to return and
get back into
the workforce i think it's really
important um to get that message out
so there might be some cultural things
especially with with corporations and
getting to the top but
in terms of the entrepreneurship side is
it just a mindset thing is it just
i mean i see so many women who want to
start business why are they not looking
at
the advertising industry well we're
hiring so they should go
we've got a lot of open positions we're
growing like crazy look i think
i think it's about finding the right
company
and a company with the right culture
that allows you
to um you know be able to
balance your work life and your personal
life right
um but i think that with the way the
world is going right now and certainly
covid has
um brought some good in it right we've
learned how to work in a more remote
environment there's more tools than
you've ever had before
um you know you can do you can do like i
said you can do a meeting
on the side of a lacrosse game um you
know and
or at your dining room table it allows
people to be able to
to um pursue things now that i think
they weren't able to pursue in the past
so technology i think will help allow
more people and
and create that entry point at which
they can start to pursue
a professional career interesting you
mentioned technology because
you know nina hearing the live chat is
saying do you think barbara
that it's the technology side of things
that's putting women off
um i i don't think so i mean i i
well let me take that back because i
have a wonderful friend who's a
brilliant brilliant attorney and
she is definitely not comfortable with
basics basic computer skills so i think
there is for sure
something around the fact that maybe i
left
the workforce when i was um you know
in my my my early mothering years
and now i want to make the return back
into the workforce and i don't
know what excel is you know or i don't
know what
word is other than word
right so but but i say you know what
um ask your kids they'll teach you how
to do word
and do excel it's it's not that hard
and if you can operate a smartphone you
can operate technology
and it's not it's very intuitive so they
shouldn't be afraid of technology they
should just try to lean into it
um and i think um you know don't let
that be a barrier
the sort of comes to mind is mary kay
ash who kept getting
pushed over and pushed aside and told
you know oh you're just thinking like a
woman and never got promoted and then
the person she was training got promoted
to be her boss
and she she quit the corporate world and
then wrote her manifesto for
how women should be treated and how
women can empower themselves
and she said well you know what i wrote
this thing how about i just go build it
and she created mary kate cosmetics off
of those principles
um when is when is the barbara
manifesto being released or is it
already out
i think i'm gonna have to write the book
because um
i get a lot of questions about how you
know i'm
i'm a very active mom um i
i sit on the board of my kid's school
i'm
at every game i can throw a football
um you know i i can play basketball with
them
and i can be in the boardroom right
after and
be able to compartmentalize my world
you know and my kids obviously come
first and i have very funny stories like
many other working moms where
you're in a meeting and your kids are
blowing up your phone you're thinking oh
my god the house is burning down or
something's wrong and you pick up the
phone and my son says mom where's my
gummies
right i lost my gummy bears or where's
my bear
or you know whatever it is but i think
yeah there's a book out there
and i think um i think women have a
really
great emotional quotient that they can
bring to the workforce that i think is
really special
and um can help build a culture and a
sense of
family at work and i think that's one of
the things that
um we really promote here at ludwig plus
is a very strong culture
a very assured sense
of values a way of working
that makes us
be able to deliver the value for our
clients
and create an environment where people
can really become their full selves and
i think
um you know i i don't think it's just a
female thing
but we certainly are wired differently
and um i think it definitely plays a
very strong role in
in what uh we're creating here for sure
so for the
women i guess especially out there
watching who might be doubting
themselves who feel like i can't have it
all uh it's not possible to be an
entrepreneur and have
kids let alone eight kids and everything
you're doing if they're in a moment of
doubt
and feeling like it's not possible don't
support it and it's just not gonna
happen and they had to
fast forward this video to get to this
point just as a reminder to themselves
to stay strong and and that is possible
what would your message to them be
you know look we all have moments of
confidence you know you question your
confidence you question
the next move can i do this and i don't
care if you're a man or a woman
um i know i experienced it when i first
became
chief marketing officer of mccann which
is one of the top
agencies on the planet and i called a
very dear friend a man
a man who's a mentor of mine and i said
oh my god i'm gonna be
the cmo of this big you know ad agency
that i
always admired and it was um you know
definitely an awesome you know
experience and an
awesome responsibility and um
and he said what are you talking about
he goes every day you wake up you're
going to look in the mirror
and have these moments and you just
you've been doing it so just keep doing
it and take one step at a time
and i don't care if it's your profession
or your personal life you're going to
face
moments in life because life throws you
curveballs right so whether you're
building a business
or you're being thrown a curveball i
always
say take one step at a time
because you will always win you will get
to
the finish line you will get to that
goal whatever that goal is
one step at a time and i think that's
where you build confidence because
don't make it so grand to achieve and
that's why
back to your very beginning question of
how do you unearth the soul of the brand
how do you help an entrepreneur who has
this very big
aspiration how did they get there will
you brainstorm what are all the things i
need to do to get there and then what
did i tell you you do next
what can i do today to get there
and then tomorrow morning what's another
thing i can do
and just be action oriented we have a
saying here at the agency
gsd get done now right
it's not about not being thoughtful but
it's about
taking action don't wait to do something
go get it done if you can do it in five
minutes do it right now
because you might forget to do it and
then it's too late
and life is too short and your goals are
too big
so just start taking steps
right it's just like you know i say to
other mothers when you had a baby
it didn't come with an instruction
manual
right nobody said here's your
instruction manual to
change the diaper or be a mom or nurse
that baby or feed the baby
there's no instruction manual to be an
entrepreneur
yes you can read a lot of books and you
can get a lot of advice but at the end
of the day
take a step forward hat be action
oriented
gsdn right get done now
i love it barbara yola's in the house
every party it's amazing
somebody asked on the chat how many
women in our company
70 of our company's women and how
how big how many people are in the
company just about to hit 50.
i love it i love it all right for people
watching
on youtube uh who want to learn more
about you dive more into your world the
book's not out yet but where do you want
them to go is it instagram
twitter youtube your website where do
you want them to go to learn more about
you
plus reach out happy to help any women
out there are thinking about becoming
entrepreneurs we're happy to help if
you're running a business we're happy to
come in
and help you unearth the soul of your
brand right from the inside out
ludwig plus perfect we'll link that up
youtube description below
barbara appreciate the time the energy
the love we made it happen
your your soul is amazing and i'm
looking forward to having you back on
um at some point in the future all right
take care
if you want to see another one-on-one i
did with a badass woman entrepreneur
check out my lisa bill you interview
it's right there next to me i think
you'll enjoy it continue to believe
and i'll see you there part of my own
personal mission is to break the idea
that women should be
anything right you should be an
entrepreneur you should be a mother at
the end of the day it really is what do
you want to be